[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soit il est bienvenu sur france 24 à la
une ce soir jour de vote en angola 14
millions d'électeurs étaient appelés aux
urnes ce mercredi pour choisir des
députés et un président pour l'instant
aucun taux de participation n'a été
publié selon les observateurs portugais
le scrutin s'est déroulé normalement les
détails dans ce journal les conséquences
de la guerre en ukraine dans les pays de
la zone cfa des conséquences liées
directement à la chute de l'euro face au
dollar le franc cfa round excès sur la
devise européenne décroche également et
fait plonger les économies des pays
concernés c'est le cas au congo
brazzaville reportage à suivre et puis
ce soir nous recevons eddie komboïgo
leaders du congrès pour la démocratie et
le progrès l'ex-parti au pouvoir fondé
par blaise compaore nous lui demanderons
ce qu'il pense du retour de l'ancien
président au burkina et de la polémique
qui a qui en a suivi et son regard sur
la situation dans son pays interview à
suivre
les angolais sont allés voter ce
mercredi s'il s'agit du vote le plus
serré de l'histoire post indépendance
pour s'assurer de la transparence du
processus électoral des jeunes ont pris
l'initiative de photographier les pv en
fin de journée et côté opposition
l'unita a demandé à ses partisans
d'aller voter mais surtout de surveiller
le scrutin caroline l'embolie
voter asseyez-vous c'est le nom donné à
cette campagne lancée par le parti de
position unità après avoir voté la
question de rentrer à la maison
l'objectif est de contrôler le vote car
nous avons remarqué que pendant
l'organisation du processus électoral il
ya eu un manque de transparence de la
part de la commission nationale
électorale donc ce manque de
transparence le manque d'équité dans
l'organisation du processus électoral
font que nous sommes là pour contrôler
le volage
la campagne n'a pas été suivi dans tous
les bureaux de vote lors de ce jour
d'élection présidentielle
le candidat de l'unita à d'alberto costa
junior se présente contre l'actuel
président joão lourenço qui brigue un
second mandat
lourenço dirige le mp l ancien parti
unique tout puissant qui dirige le pays
depuis son indépendance en 1975 le mpla
a dépêché 53000 représentants pour
observer le vote le manque de
transparence inquiète aussi la société
civile
l'association modèle avait appelé les
électeurs à rester jusqu'à la clôture
des bureaux de vote leur objectif
photographier les pv et les rendre
public rapidement
nous attendons ici qu'ils affichent le
dépouillement du bureau de vote ensuite
nous allons prendre en photo les procès
verbaux et les diffuser à toutes les
institutions qui voudront les avoir
l'idée est de faire ça puis d'aller dans
d'autres bureaux de vote partout dans le
quartier pour avoir autant de pv que
possible environ 2000 observateurs
internationaux ont aussi été dépêchés
les résultats officiels ne sont pas
attendus avant plusieurs jours
et puis sachez que pour le moment aucun
taux de participation n'a été publiée la
commission électorale a indiqué que le
comptage pardon il est encore en cours
la ca ne parle d'un succès retentissant
pour des élections qui se sont passés
dans le calme les observateurs portugais
quand elles ont affirmé que le vote
s'est déroulé normalement
en guinée le rapport des assises
nationales a été remis ce mercredi à
conakry au président de la transition
guinéenne
un document qui contient la vie des
guinéens sur toutes les questions liées
à la transition s'est assise avait été
boycotté par les principaux partis
politiques du pays mais pour le colonel
mamadou doumbouya ces assises devraient
permettre de réconcilier les guinéens
écouter
l'occasion a été donnée à chacun
de dire la vérité
10 - sa part de vérité si moment
solennel et pour nous
l'expression de notre détermination
à apaiser les coeurs et les rancoeurs
écoutez son projet surtout lorsque
celui-ci sont infusés au mépris de
l'appartenance à une même nation
la reprise des travaux du dialogue
national au tchad un dialogue en vue
d'une transition les participants vont
devoir mettre en place les un sens du
dialogue avec l'adoption d'un règlement
intérieur
parmi les 1400 participants en compte
des organisations de la société civile
elles ont déjà pris des dispositions
pour faire entendre en temps réel leurs
propositions la correspondance à
n'djamena de mamadou djite ndiaye
c'est reparti pour les travaux du
dialogue national inclusif et souverain
le dialogue en fait commencé 72 heures
après son ouverture aux miss officiel
les raisons avancées pour justifier
cette longue pause sont d'ordre
logistique d'après le comité
d'organisation
mais de l'avis de plusieurs experts
c'était une façon de donner du temps aux
négociations en cours pour faire revenir
sur la table des discussions le
composantes qui rejette ce dialogue à
savoir le mouvement citoyen rakita mas
le parti les transformateurs le
regroupement politique une nation pour
tous est d'autres personnalités de poids
qui manquent à l'appel les travaux ont
débuté avec la lecture du rapport du
d'activité du comité d'organisation
après quoi le ministre en charge de la
réconciliation et président du comité hr
ibni oumar a suspendu les travaux pour
une reprise prévue demain à 9 heures
c'est une des conséquences de la guerre
en ukraine l'euro chute depuis plusieurs
mois face au dollar en juillet il est
même descendue à un taux historiquement
bas un décrochage qui a des conséquences
sur les économies des pays de la zone
cfa car leurs monnaies qui est indexée
sur la devise européenne
exemple au congo brazzaville où les
ménages s'inquiètent de la hausse des
prix des produits de première nécessité
reportage de rosé piotte
pauline malonga tient un restaurant de
fortune devant chez elle depuis plus de
20 ans aujourd'hui à cause de la baisse
du franc cfa les produits alimentaires
importés coûte plus cher elle doit donc
s'adapter actuellement format le marché
c'est la jungle ce moment là je suis
parti à la retraite j'en arrive là on
n'a pas augmenté les prix mais plutôt
j'ai fait que diminuer la quantité
ok pour moi on puisse acheter en moi
quelque chose si tu augmentes le plus à
vienne est au bout du seul mois la
république du congo importe son
imposante ses besoins alimentaires
ces importations sont payées en dévises
étrangères face à la baisse du français
phare de nombreux congolais ces rues
donc vers le dollar et certains
cambistes comme ça car yoko peine à
répondre à la demande le taux sur le
marché informel dépasse aujourd'hui le
taux officiel d'environ 650 francs pour
un dollar les jours passent et la vraie
manne dollars était beaucoup auraient
cherché tpour pourrait chercher mais
c'est pour cela enlève en est à 690 des
fois on vient nous demandait le dollar
si on en a pas parce que
ça vient
ça ne vient pas aux
bandits et président de la chambre de
commerce de brazzaville il explique que
la baisse du franc cfa n'est pas qu'une
mauvaise nouvelle elle favorise les
exportateurs particulièrement les
pétroliers qui pourraient voir leurs
bénéfices augmenter cette année pour lui
les autorités congolaises doivent
profiter de cette manne pour venir en
aide aux importateurs et aux ménages un
certain nombre d'opérateurs importants
en dollars et cela ils sont impactées et
immédiatement et a un impact sur le
niveau des prix il faudrait que le
gouvernement accélère le plan
d'assistance
pour que les produits de première
nécessité soient
soutenus sous mentionné et surtout qui
est un véritable contrôle de prix en
avril le gouvernement avait déjà annoncé
la mise en place d'un fonds de
résilience pour soutenir les ménages il
n'a pas encore été appliqué
ce soir nous recevant eddie komboïgo
leaders du congrès pour la démocratie et
le progrès l'ex-parti au pouvoir fondé
par blaise compaore bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous merci d'être venu sur notre
plateau alors tout d'abord quelle est
votre fonction parce que on dit vous
êtes président du parti mais d'autres le
conteste qu'elle est définitivement
votre fonction aujourd'hui notamment je
le cite et quand même achille tapsoba
qui lui revendique aussi la présidence
du parti
de ce soir
l'occasion pour le présenter les
condoléances
pour dire vrai le congrès pour la
démocratie et le progrès a tenu son
congrès ordinaire en décembre
2021 et à le congrès des cow boys comme
président du parti
alors merci pour votre réponse comme ça
on peut continuer les interviews
j'aimerais avoir votre réaction sur le
retour de blaise compaoré au burkina
faso et surtout toute la polémique qui a
suivi ce retour je rappelle qu'il a été
condamné dans le procès sankara à la
perpétuité et qu'il n'a pas été arrêtée
ni emprisonné ça a créé une polémique
notamment chez les victimes
de l'assassinât du président du
président sankara quelle est votre
réaction est ce que il est ce que blaise
compaoré est un justiciable comme les
autres où est ce qu'il est au dessus de
la loi non les seconds paulette
justiciable comme les autres mais était
un ancien président et aujourd'hui la
justice a été dit le juge n'a été fait
et nous sommes dans un pays en guerre où
la nation en péril il a plu au président
dany bardet vite l ensemble des anciens
chefs d'état de lever dire pour l'aider
il quand même ans et la perpétuité le
sud pourquoi le pr pourquoi ce procès
alors bien sûr avoir tenu ce procès là
les militaires au pouvoir qui ont qui
ont pris le pouvoir il ya six mois
aurait pu ne pas maintenir le procès
pour des raisons les raisons que vous
dites un pays en guerre situation très
compliquée on en parlera notamment d'un
point de vue sécuritaire pourquoi
organiser ce procès et ne pas respecter
le verdict non le il faut organiser le
procès le procès est organisé verdict a
été donné aujourd'hui et nous prenons
acte le compte de l'ademe ont passé un
après at il a été appelé par le
président habib a parce que la nation en
péril sans nation pas d'institution y
compris judiciaires et applications de
peine et donc de ce fait il faut d'abord
que nous réunissions nous initions shell
cherche dans l'unité sacré pour le
conquérir l'intégrité du territoire et
nous allons reconstruire les
institutions alors certains vous diront
qu'il ya pas de réconciliation sans
impunité mais nous allons aborder
d'autres questions nous n'avons pas
malheureusement beaucoup de temps pour
faire cette interview j'aimerais aussi
vous poser une question sur votre regard
sur la situation sécuritaire au burkina
faso l'arrivée
des militaires il ya six mois avait
donné de l'espoir pour une amélioration
des situations sécuritaires mais
malheureusement c'est toujours très
compliqué pourquoi c'est toujours aussi
compliqué est ce que le burkina besoin
de plus des 2 notamment de la communauté
internationale le burkina a besoin qu'on
lève les barrières au niveau de la
cedeao d'une vidéo qui empêche le
burkina à s'équiper en armement nous
posons des questions pourquoi les
terroristes sont plus équipés que les
armées locales
c'est vrai on ne souhaite pas que les
armées dessus reçoit éparpillés dans
tout le pays on se pose des questions en
afrique a aucun pays qui produit des
armes en une arme de guerre on sait qui
produit qu'ils achètent et vocale des
citations donc il faudrait que nos
partenaires bilatéraux multilatéraux
nous aide à savoir déjà où viennent ces
armes et alléger les procédures pour que
le burkina puisse se doter d'armes
sophistiquées pour faire face
alors très rapidement vous avez demandé
à la france de revoir ses accords avec
les pays africains et le burkina faso
pour vous pouvez vous être un peu plus
précis je n'ai pas demandé à la france
des menteurs et de le voir ces accords
gilles demandé aux partenaires
bilatéraux et multilatéraux de revoir
les accords les barrières qui empêchent
les pays du sahel à s'équiper
normalement des arts vous savez quand un
pays du sahel veut s'équiper bid a fait
mieux s'équiper soit qu'il ait un accord
de la cedeao d'abord et ensuite un
accord au niveau de l'union européenne
pour que le pays qui doivent rendre les
armes puissent accepter de les évincer
un nouveau pic au pays acheteurs le
message est passé merci beaucoup eddie
komboïgo donc président du congrès pour
la démocratie et le progrès merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur
youtube c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique restait avec nos l'info
continue sur france 24
[Musique]